l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj non so se ho capito bene non
hai capito un cazzo faringei cosa vuol
dire fare in genere tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono faringei e
oggi siamo in un nuovo video con la hit
da ivana ma sono un master del design ma
non chiamarmi prima ma i ragazzi ho
voluto fare un episodio sul sull'ipad
perché sto morendo o scaricato gioco
quello tre tra i più scaricati sulle
sull'apple store che sarebbe browser in
austria cioè un europa ragazzi dix che
figo della madonna un modello di
abercrombie eventi si sblocchi a noi
capitolo thaci però stai calmo zio note
che ti incazzi ma c'è la chat c'è la
chat pubblica scriverò qualcosa che
lascerà il mio segno nella storia tipo
di puzza la suocera suo era cosa ho
scritto di pulsa la sua h bene così ma
david è come se partita gioca per fare
il tasto ce l'ha scritto gioca grosso
così bene ci sono andata io il mio per i
giochi su ipad sono un fenomeno e
abbiate pazienza ma qua
ciò la banana che mi dà la forza che non
vedevo l'ora cos'è è una roba troppo
seria c'è la guerra e tu ti metti a
giocare lì in poi sulle rocce browse il
cuore pieno di gioia e di banane sei
pronto se certo sorgente io io sono
sorgente sul ragazzo occhiaperti
muoviamoci va bene zio ma tu ci hai dei
capelli che non puoi esistere jacob gol
ascolta ceco bolshoi dei capelli che
gesù santo prendi un parrucchiere
ragazzi ci sono due tizi che sta
parlando di one direction e justin
bieber non so perché avevo ucciderli
adesso mi è stato ordinato così o match
di carne morto a noi ma l'attesa adesso
è morto perfetto vai tu miller nato
ragazzi e vado come i ragazzi non si
perdano fatto una matrix può parlare
come scrive ai proiettili incredibile
[Musica]
sparite o rieter actions to action tra i
ragazzi non so neanche come si gioca
faccio guardano avanti allora ok ma non
è che si muove ma la mia città di
cassano maledizione no no no no no no no
no no non hai questa somma va beh ma son
troppi regalo se quella roba laggiù c'è
un carro armato mamma va veramente al
sicuro perché a me sembrava una
macchinina della kiko quella ragazzi non
so come faccio a far fuori un carro
armato col fucile me lo spiegate ma è
questa qua ci sono i bomber l'effetto
vai bene però c'è
minchia valentino che figo ragazzi è la
cosa più saggia che abbia mai visto mai
grandi linee sarà anzi veloce la mia
mira ragazzi la mia [ __ ] mila e
bellissime come cazzo ti permetti che ti
uccido la mamma e la suocera tumori
pranzo c'è botta di culo posso salva
ancora bazooka tipo anche adesso
pam pam sucate mil bene però vabbè mica
sono troppo forte che ho vinto parma
perché ma perché a me e io la guerra
sergente di prim'ordine è sbloccato un
nuovo fratello jacob mol che non userò
mai perché ha dei capelli che non si
possono guardare
voglio richiede attaccando me ne frega
un cazzo richiedi un attacco era quei
capelli bruttissimo ma molotov razzi
incendiario messo che sta chiamando la
mamma sapere che comunque lascia perdere
sta cosa andiamo avanti perché noi che
posso sta sempre allo stesso punto
l'obiettivo della visione elimina la eva
non ho fatto in tempo siamo nella merda
fino al collo ma guarda se continui a
fatti colpire un altro po forse sì ma lo
sai ha attratto sono io anno e jacob
quello che se ti pareva che non erano
data jacob e dei morire anche tu prima o
poi non è che puoi prenderti proietti
come prassi hulk male dice ecco ragazzo
italo in queste situazioni di merda
spiegatelo fuori è il software te pareva
far qualcosa dice che ciò è ciò di
panikkar ci mancherebbe bye bye bye come
madonna la bye bye bye bye va ci sono
dove sono gli stronzi ecco merda via via
via via via via via e va beh posso
rinunciare indietro valenti che fingono
dai seriamente
social madonna che che basta io io io ho
vinto tutto fuori lanciato una granata
l'intesa tra la cosa più [ __ ] che abbia
mai fatto è sempre stato un fenomeno ai
giochi di guerra ma mio dio eccolo lì è
crepato ragazzi nel mulino che vorrei
tanti soldati e e fa vigente in una roba
usa l'abilità del fratello per
richiedere un attacco aereo a attacco
ero pronto che figo a un'amica fosse
jacob ai dei capelli da schifo ma ti sai
muovere bravo o ti guarda lì il
bombardamento mio diario arriva anche
skrillex col dubstep calcio al d'arte
[Musica]
elimina ricordi alla testa due ma sono
fatti 25 fate vedere cosa dicono i miei
amici in chat non perché sono curioso
baù quella baiano che bello ragazzi io e
la mia banana siamo troppo no cosa ho
cliccato nella mappa no siri che cazzo
vuoi che caso vuoi tu maledizione
contente ma gode tua mamma mia madre ma
che cosa ne pensi tu tifavi j siri
non sapevo che cartesio facesse video su
videogiochi come ho fatto a uscire male
l'ho sbagliato
hai rotto il cazzo si rimpiazza fatto
uscire ho fatto nemmeno apposta ma
edizione porto con la terza ragazzi
perché sono siamo messi malissimo è una
roba è bello mi piace quando questo si è
messo a correre per fermarsi davanti
all'altro che ha mica ho già vinto
praticamente ma il geko bike usa la
potenza dei tuoi capelli è la madonna
vai con la ghiandaia imitatrice mai come
feste ci siamo lo prestano a in aquila
vabbè pazienza ragazzi è una cosa troppo
p che sta facendo ma la bomba non scappa
manuela voglio rinunciare che riesco
cazzo se tutti nascondi nei cespugli lui
da fuori ma cosa ragazzi sparate vista
coltellata juan non è chi è colpito
prova con fai vedere che vale più di
edward fai qualcosa invece di stare
fermo io e la mia banana vinceremo la
guerra averle banane che siamo messi
malissimo usa lancia razzi ma dai dove
lo prendono dove prende posso usare la e
dove cazzo lo tenevo prima sfida vita
dove era celato nelle mutande o cosa bye
bye bye bye bye velo ragazzi sono
diventato un killer spietatissimo bravo
io basta mi sono state fatte è stato
giocando a pallavolo ci siamo soldati
siate rapidi e decisi andiamo nei
mandati al castello a devono sapere
peach tipo mario credo non sia d'accordo
ragazzi provoca un ultimo i nazisti
sterminati
che bei ricordi ragazzi elimina tutti i
nemici vai ce la posso fare
sì ma perché questo ci ha già visti sì
ma stai calmo di morire pam l'hanno
preso sì l'ho preso questo devi spararli
20 volte in faccia sono non muoiono
carica maledizione ma cosa sta cosa
epica ogni tanto succede che caccia la
dubstep bombardamento vai jacob co sto
qua serpe in seno un cazzo serve solo
per chiamare la mamma a casa per
chiedere se è pronto a tavola e poi
esplode tutto ma non serve un cazzo
oltre a questo fa questo si stanno
facendo le pippe a terra filo un fucile
nel didietro posso fund fi
prendilo per mano viviamo felici e
contenti i ragazzi è un gioco anche
d'amore questo che bello ti devo la vita
no guarda mi devi la figlia del dottor
ho vinto meglio così concludo qua perché
mi sta facendo male la mano a tener su
la banana con tutto l'ipad ragazzi a
parte il fatto che questo gioco è la
cosa più bella della vita voglio vedere
la chat perché siete tutti dei figli di
penati con il cedente socievoli
quindi ragazzi e che possono chiudere
qui però fatto 345 mischia non so più
contare con che a parte le pubblicità
del gioco della chat di tutto il resto
volevo salutare anche siri perché si ri
sì li merita ciao siri sta andando via
ci vediamo ok ciao
apache rogazzo entusiasmo non so se ho
capito bene anch'io falcier o gaza
che cazzo dici cerchi fa dj su youtube
ok
ecco cosa ho trovato su internet su
fatti lunga fa vj con ragazzi concludo
più il video come al solito ragazze il
vino è piaciuto al sotto momento mi
piace anche a faccia di facebook che
come noi video trovate la descrizione se
non ce l'avresti discreti che ci vediamo
al prossimo video belle ragazze